ça t'arrive de reporter à tout ce qu'on
a fait et te demander comment on est
encore en vie c'est pas tes vrais
cheveux blancs laisse tomber c'est
culturel où les deux super guerrière
comme si battante qui ont élevé wonder
woman combat post écoles on a ouvert
notre boutique à nous on déchire on a
une baisse de 4 193 milles polar fout de
moi quelqu'un de neige est mis à carte
je m'appelle que la laune je vais
investir 1,7 million de dollars
on adore avoir un million de dollars et
si j'en crois mon expérience limitée les
affaires ne font pas toujours bon ménage
et indestructible mettez vous à
nordiques petter ma tête n'est pas petit
c'est juste ma poitrine qui est monsieur
clermont n'a va présenter un nouveau
produit a un super soirée elle veut
juste nous voler nos idées on va faire
bédié cette [ __ ] vous savez en béton
armé que vous veniez ben muna tout une
enfant j'entendais les vols elle est
capable
je suis content de m'être fait des abdos
vous allez nous rendre tout de suite
notre encontre
[Musique]
celui et mimo pointant lesquelles si
j'étais branché je t'épouserais piment
indien jeu le pierre ils sont très forts
une petite tranche peut suffire a besoin
flammes ces piments sont très forts moi
ça c'est du lait de chèvre ça va lui
tapissé laws of ages